[Music]
you know I we have a line of products a
family of products in market and I've
said over and over I think even on your
show a t3s will be the market leader for
us Xbox one s it's the more affordable
console plays all the same games as the
4k blu-ray I mean you know the spiel
it's it will be the the console that
sells X is for the customer wants the
very best experience whether you're on a
1080p TV or a 4k TV you're gonna have a
great experience I have an X on both at
home and load time super sampling things
that you see on a 1080p TV were
fantastic that's not for everybody
it's like when we built the elite
controller we didn't try to say to
everybody if you need an extra
controller go by the elite controller
and yet we sold a ton of those
controllers because we know in the
gaming segment there are a lot of people
who play games casually there's also a
lot of people where gaming is their
number one hobby their number one form
of entertainment and we can give them
the very best experience I've played
games with true 4k HD are on they look
fantastic
doesn't mean everybody has to go do that
so we're giving gamers choice whether we
push the innovation too far it's hard to
do that with gamers gamers but you know
I guess we'll see I feel very confident
about the product that we have coming to
market
I don't love the idea or the practice of
us paying so other platforms can't play
kind of use a certain gun in a game or
go do a certain level now I know I say
that in xbox history back with DLC
windows with Cod like I understand the
fingers are pointing right back at Xbox
so I can only be Who I am like so maybe
it's not the best PR answer but I don't
like that and when there's games that
come along
cuphead is a good example actually where
it comes along as the game this one in
the ID program and the team had certain
ambition about what they wanted to go do
and together with them we wanted to
invest more we saw more opportunity and
what that turned into was us having an
exclusive game on our platform because
we continued to invest with them in the
game you know that's a game that
probably wouldn't have happened the way
it did if we didn't invest the way we
did one of the reasons PC is still so
strong and frankly strong it now is it's
probably ever been in gaming just
because it's an open platform and you
put a game on PC and people can go go
play that game in through things like
cross play we're working to allow people
to play games together regardless of
where you bought the game so we just put
a killer instinct in steam as an example
allowing people who have bought the game
on on Windows or an Xbox or on Steam
just to go play together and I think if
you're really about trying to drive just
a specific device and you say okay I
looked at the gaming the gaming
opportunity all up it's a single device
opportunity maybe that's an approach we
don't see it that way kind of getting
caught in a definition of gaming that's
about me trying to do everything I can
to get you to buy one specific device to
play one specific variant of games it's
not really about growing the business so
gaming is an ecosystem as opposed to a
box oh absolutely it is as a games
industry how do we make
speaker how do we do things to help
developers build the best games that
they can build using cloud using local
whatever they want to use and reach as
many players as they can not just
players but also viewers this year more
people are gonna watch video games than
play video games and play time is up so
both these numbers are going up that's
all good for the games industry because
it expands the footprint of number of
people that care about your franchise in
your game oh we talked to Sony all the
time I mean we're with Minecraft on
PlayStation we have to be one of the
biggest games on the on their platform
in terms of sales and gameplay so same
thing with Nintendo the relationship
with Nintendo on this front spend
stronger like I think everybody can see
that they've been great supporters and
we continue to collaborate with them I
think you know sony's view is different
Sony I mean they should talk about what
their view is in this space if it's
better for gamers I have a hard time
thinking like why we shouldn't go do
this
especially when you're trying to make
the gaming business a bigger business
kind of grow it get more games create
more opportunity especially in the indie
space actually you know you think you're
creating an online indie game and you're
worried about you're gonna create five
shards of your game the Steam version
the Xbox Live on PC the Xbox where's in
a Playstation verse maybe that the
switch version creates hard matchmaking
scenarios you're managing multiple
online like it we should help developers
not make their lives more difficult I
know that there's a certain view that
says
if my friends have this console and they
can't play with people who buy another
console that's a reason they go buy my
console that reasons not going to go
away right so we're putting minecraft
out there as one of the biggest games on
any platform allowing people to play
together regardless of what device they
buy
I don't think everybody's taking that
same approach to the ecosystem so I'm
never gonna call anything a lost cause
but I think some of the fundamental
reasons in certain scenarios they're not
really going away so I don't know what
would change I think it's incredibly
important to the industry I mean
actually teaming up for it but funny
when I came to Brazil my first visit was
to garage two to seven indie developer
here for us Brazil to go talk to him
about the games that they're building
last time I was here at BGSU add our
Etana which was our first idea at Xbox
Brazil game now there are a ton of id
game developers here in Brazil I think
you get some of the greatest creativity
out of small teams that are trying to do
something new and sometimes those ideas
will lead there they're finding their
way into a broader bigger games over
time you know Brendon and green and I
were talking about battle royale just
today here and I was a mod now it's a
genre and you see other games kind of
going off and adding that genre to their
franchise kind of starts off more ideas
[ __ ] ends up impacting some of the
biggest franchises on the planet I think
that innovation pipe is important I was
really proud this year at e3 about the
diversity of games from developers
everywhere that showed up on our stage
and ID was incredibly strong the last
night I thought looked fantastic there's
some just really really striking games
[Music]
we're close we're really climbing up so
I have a little dashboard I go to it's
my secret but I can see all the games
where they are then getting approvals in
pipeline I know the games that are
coming for the original Xbox we don't
think we've announced them all we have
to do this in partnership with partners
and stuff to do it but we're still on
track like I feel really good the games
look great
some of the games hold up really well
some of them don't but but the gameplay
mechanics and kind of what put the smile
on your face 15 years ago playing those
games you know those are things that are
still there I see a like crimson skies
getting back to go play crimson skies
fantastic and the game actually looks
really good even though it's obviously
been around we and continue to invest in
back compat because it matters not
because somebody else doesn't have it if
somebody else did it tomorrow and we
wouldn't stop because we see it as a
commitment to our customers of the games
that you buy from us we were here in
Brazil where 360s still a vibrant
platformer and when I'm doing press with
with the Brazilians they asked me well
should I go buy a 360 if and what I say
to you if that's the right value for you
go buy a 360 our commitment to you is
we've got over 400 360 games if and when
you move to Xbox one those games are
going to come with you you don't have to
rebuy the games I think some of the
rationale in previous generations of our
data shows it's kind of justification of
we don't want you playing on the old box
we want you to go buy our new box I want
to give gamers no choice and it's about
growing gaming not being divisive and
trying to artificially move you ahead
that's why Xbox 1x plays the same games
Xbox 1s does plays that looks better
PC's done this for years it's not rocket
science and how you figure this out
and you know it's it's pretty important
to me as the somebody gets to run the
platform that we continue to invest in
that I think about how successful Xbox
has been and what I think about is how
many people are engaged in something to
do with Xbox playing our games watching
things on mixer on xbox live on our
console but I look in those in aggregate
and so I don't it's it's not actually
about how many Xbox one X is do I go
sell or how many S's
do I sell or even how many of any one
individual game that I go sell I look at
are we growing the number of people have
a relationship with Xbox in some way it
could be an Android customer in China
playing Minecraft but that's a person
who's connected to our platform who's
able to use mixers able to connect to
Xbox Live meet their friends online
that's really the metric for growth
right now I think if we get so focused
just on hardware sales at this point all
up as as gamers we lose sight of what's
going on around the console business
consoles and board I love the console
space but it's part of the gaming
business it's not total so I just don't
define success by any one individual
version of our console and how many
cells are we growing the business are we
growing the number of customers
yeah thank you good question
[Music]